Guten tag ( En allemand qui veut dire bonjour ) et bienvenue dans l'épisode 2 de notre let's play sur The Last Guardian,
le dernier jardin.
Voilà petit remix by Squeezie.
C'est nul.
Souvenez-vous Tricot venait de péter les armures des gens
et il était tout affolé j'ai dû le caresser comme ça,
Comme je caresse Lua (son chat) tous les matins avant de venir faire des vidéos
Et ça l'a apaisé et il s'est redirigé vers cette cage avec le truc bleu dedans il l'a sniffé
Donc je sais pas si il faut retourner en arrière ou si il faut nous aussi sniffer des choses ^^
C'est chelou, j'pense pas que nos amis qui ont fait le jeu voulait qu'on sniffe des choses en jouant mais...
Alors, on va, descend descend descend lâche l'oreille, lâche deux secondes ton animal
Je sais que tu as beaucoup d'affection pour lui
Du coup est-ce qu'il y a un truc à faire ici ? Ou pas du tout ?
Il a l'air vraiment intrigué par ce truc, peut-être qu'il faut que je trouve une clé
Ou alors je dis n'importe quoi
En plus j'ai plus le miroir, c'est vrai j'ai plus le miroir
Bon à mon avis il faut remonter il s'est pas mis là pour rien
Faut aller là haut? C'est ça, faut aller là ? On va tenter !
Laisse moi me mettre debout
Excuses moi, excuses moi, excuses moi j'fais n'imp'
Mais NAAAAN !
Alors j'vais retourner là-haut,Tricot,
On va voir ce qu'on peut y faire
J'suis là, j'suis là
Mais j'suis pas sûr que ce soit le bon truc à faire la
Revenir en arrière en fait.
J'suis pas sûr du tout, bon
Je crois que j'étais pas allé là haut, dans le trou
On va aller voir
Allez j'ai besoin de toi mon gars
Allez bouges pas
Ok
Je sais plus si on était allé par là, ou pas
J'suis là, j'suis là, il pleure déjà le con
Ah ok donc on peut pas monter par là, doit y avoir un truc à faire hein
Ah c'est horrible d'être bloqué
Bonjour c'est Lucas Hauchard ici, j'suis toujours bloqué dans cet endroit, j'sais pas ce qui faut faire
Ah y a une chaîne là
Faudrait que j'atteigne la chaîne en fait tout simplement
Mais comment je fais pour atteindre la chaîne ?
Faudrait que j'amène un objet peut être ?
C'est ça ?
Donc là Tricot ne peut pas venir y a que sa tête qui passe
Ou alors peut être que en montant sur sa tête ici
Attends, attends
Peut être que d'ici en fait je peux atteindre
OH OUI
Ooh
C'est ça qui fallait faire ! Mon dieu j'suis décoincé !
Ah c'est jouissif mon gars, ah c'est tellement jouissif quand tu te décoinces comme ça
Donc là, je me retrouve au dessus, au bord
Euuuuh mais à quoi ça me sert en fait
d'aller là
Euuh bon en fait ça m'a avancé à rien putain
Ah mais si regardez !
Et comme ça je vais pouvoir atteindre la chaîne
Ralalala
Tu sAUTES, Sss ss OUH ! Ok je l'ai pas totalement fais exprès sur la fin on va pas se mentir
Attention saute, voilàà, quand tu perds l'équilibre : saute, ça marche toujours
Allez on y va !
On monte, on monte, on monte
Tricot il est toujours bloqué en bas.
On voit sa pauvre tête.
On atteint la lumière.
On va trouver un moyen de le décoincer de l'extérieur ?
Je pense qu'il va faire le tour, il va se démerder, de toute façon il est malin Tricot !
C'est un gars malin. C'est pas notre meilleur ami pour rien !
Waaaah ok !
Et on arrive ici.
Et c'est de toute putain de beauté !
Allons dans l'herbe !
ça fait penser à Gladiator ça !
La scène où il court..euuuh..où ses gamins courent dans le..
Dans les près comme ça.
Petit moment nostalgie
Aloooors, où arrivons nous ?
On arrive..AH BAH VOILÀ !
On va lui indiquer de sauter je pense, depuis ici !
Allez viens !
Tu viens ?
Viens mon grand ! Fais le tour !
Il arrive. Je suis sûr qu'il va sauter.
Il dandine du cul comme les chat ! Putain c'est trop drôle !!
Ouuuiiiii !!
OOOHHH !!
Ça va ça va ça va tu montes tu montes tu montes !
C'eesstt bieeen mon grannnd !
Parfait
On n'est pas bien là tricot ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a ?!
Qu-est-ce qu'il y a ? Tu regardes quoi ?
Mais il y a rien.
Tu regardes juste la tour.
Pourquoi tu me fais peur ? Allez je te monte dessus, peut-être ça veut dire : "monte moi dessus"
Euuh je te mets bien cousin !
Ah !
Je te suis Trico
Ah il va sauter !
Il va sauter
Je le sens.
YEEAAH
Oooh !
Heureusement qu'il s'accroche bien ce gamin hein !
On y retourne
Fan-tas-tique
Alors !
Euh est-ce qu'on va..Je crois qu'on a plusieurs chemins possibles ici.
Soit on va tout droit là-bas
Soit on va ici. À mon avis il va falloir aller ici mais dans le doute on va commencer par aller là-bas.
Il y a rien
Il y a une petite estrade là.
Hop hop hop hop hop
Il court bien vite hein, il est très serein ce petit
Et ça mène...ça mène totalement nulle part !
Eh ben direction l'autre trou si je puis me permettre
Rien de sexuel !
Regardez il a déjà sa tête dedans HAHA
C'est ouf comment ce comportement, on dirait un vrai animal quoi !
Lua elle fait pareil elle met sa tête dans des trucs elle reste coincée
tu dois la décoincer, c'est exceptionnel
Faut que je t'aide mon gars ouuuuu...
ou tu mets ta tête juste..
C'est ça qui t'attire ?
Tu veux que je le bouge ?
Vas-y je peux le tirer donc moi je le tire.
On va l'amener vers là-bas.
Ouuaah Trico il a l'air de kiffer là !
Alors on tire on tire on tire, on va voir où ça nous mène.
Hop !
Du coup il va se mettre dans au autre trou et ça va me permettre d'accéder à quelque chose, c'est ça ?
Allez mets ta tête !
Vas-y
Vas-y mon grand !
Voiiilà
Ah il est vraiment en mode daleux, il a envie d'y aller quoi !
Aïe ! Oh putain Trico !
Je pense que je dois pouvoir y accéder par ailleurs non ?
Ouais regardez par là, on va faire ça.
Pendant qu'il a sa tête dedans et qu'il est attiré
Ah si faut qu'il sorte en fait, si faut qu'il sorte.
Allez sors de là, sors de là
Sors !
Il m'écoute plus du tout, un vrai animal. Il y a de la bouffe ça y est il s'en bat les couilles de ce que je dis !
Peut- être devoir le pousser de l'intérieur
Ok je pense qu'il faut..Ah c'est bon il s'est retiré.
Attends avant de remettre ta tête... Non... Attends, non Trico
C'est infernal
On dirait un chat tu sais, qui veut manger dans ton assiette alors qu'il a ses croquettes
Wow !
WTF
Il m'a fait peur ce con.
Donne moi la hauteur de ta tête, s'il te plaît
Je te caresse.. lève la tête !
ça veut dire lève la tête !
Trico nan !
Après en vrai je suis pas sûr que la solution c'est d'aller là haut non plus en fait
Aaah ok ! Je pense avoir compris
Je pense avoir cooompris
Pourquoi j'ai mis tant de temps
La différence entre les 3 trous c'est qu'au celui du milieu il y a de l'herbe
et que je vais pouvoir m'agripper pour monter, je pense !
Yataaa ! Oui c'est ça putain !
Mon dieu j'ai mis tellement de temps, ça fait 10 min que je cherche.
Ah je suis beaucoup moins bon que la dernière fois là pour trouver les énigmes.
C'est terrible. Du coup qu'est-ce qu'on va pouvoir faire exactement ici?
Alors on a euuuhh... On va s'imbiber de potion ?
Je suis pas sûr que se soit une bonne idée d'aller là-dedans.
Ça a l'air bien chaud en bas quand même.
Bon bah écoutez, de toute manière il n'y a pas 36 choses à faire.
On va tester.
Hop ! Je suis en hauteur maintenant, ok.
Ah et je peux la fermer, pour qu'il arrête
de péter un câble.
C'est bon !
Ça, c'est fermé !
Du coup il se détend un peu le trou du cul euuh...Trico
Ça permettait juste de libérer un peu Trico pour ensuite l'utiliser pour faire le vrai truc qu'on doit faire.
Qui je pense est ailleurs.
Hein Trico ?
Non ? Tu ne sais pas où il faut aller ?
Bah moi non plus ! Ahah !
Bon alors à mon avis du coup il faut aller là.
Ça c'est clairement pas là pour rien, il va juste mettre sa tête
il y a des herbes regardez, on va pouvoir atteindre peut être une hauteur, un truc.
Ok bah je m'éloigne, je m'éloigne, tu peux mettre ta tête je m'éloigne !
Aller
Peut être si je pars carrément à un endroit où il ne me voit plus
il va vraiment venir, il va péter un câble.
Ouais ! J'ai entendu un gros bruit. Je sais pas où il est maaiis...
On l'aime ce Trico putain !
Tu viens jusqu'à moi ?!
T'oses pas hein ?
En même temps ça doit être flippant !
Alors le problème c'est que t'aurais dû faire ça avec moi sur ton dos, je pense.
Ah bah non, je pense qu'il faut qu'il reste là-haut et je vais pouvoir monter dessus grâce à sa queue.
Ouais je pense que c'est ça.
Non reste en haut, reste en haut, reste en haut
Elle est où ta queue ?
Elle est là !
Oui !
C'est une grande queue que voici, qui va me permettre de te monter dessus
Reste là haut, reste là haut, j'arrive, j'arrive, j'arrive
C'est assez instinctif en fait par moment
Des fois c'est un peu complexe mais des fois...souvent même c'est très instinctif donc c'est assez agréable à jouer.
Merci mon pote ! Je vais pouvoir accéder à l'intérieur et te laisser seul, voilà
WOOOW attends attends !   Aïe !
Mais.... tu n'as pas honte ?!
Vous n'avez pas honte M. Trico ?
Eeuuuuuuh bah là on est clairement bloqué, et clairement je vais devoir te monter dessus.
Je.....je ne vois pas d'autres solutions
Alors ok je suis sur toi
Est-ce qu'il y a pas un petit rebord un petit truc ?
Ah tu veux sauter !
Ça fait peur quand tu fais ça Trico !
Mais mec tu tiens sur quoi là ?!
Ah tu fais vraiment le...le ninja ! ok
Bah écoute merci euuh... starfoullah
Mais tu vas pas sauter là.
Laaaa tu vas pas sauter
tu vas pas sauter parce que regarde il faut que
je passe à gauche et tu vas sauter !!
Le con il va sauter !!
Tu arrêtes de faire le fou Trico.
On est bon ? Je te fais pas chier là à être comme ça sur ton front mec ?
Bon bah il nous a mis bien hein !
Ça te fait du bien l'eau ?
C'est tellement mignon il se roule, regardez le il est tout content !
On dirait un vrai putain de chat
C'est vrai ça ! Tu as dit que tu avait peur de l'eau.
Ah mais il a peut être peur de la profondeur
et quand c'est juste une petite flaque il kiffe
Il y a une deuxième Trico ?
Ahah il fait la même tête que moi !
On y va ! On y va direct !
On a trouvé ta meuf ! On y va ensemble mon grand ?
Allez j'te suis. Vas-y monte, monte comme tu sais faire là-haut.
Vas-y, j'pose la manette. Vas-y ! Allez Trico.
Maintenant on y va !
Alors, on va aller là-dedans
J'ai compris
Il faut aller à l'intérieur pour réussir à aller tout en haut
Il y a un, deux Tricots je comprends plus là
En même temps il s'appelle Tricot hein !
Tricot, le tricot, quand tu tricotes il y a deux aiguilles hein !
Tout est corrélation
Ouh la, là par contre c'est le gros vide
On dirait que je peux escalader ça
A mon avis c'est ce qu'il faut faire
Ah là haut il y a un levier
Il y a un levier mon gars
mais j'ai l'impression... putain mais il faut.. nan..
A mon avis il faut que je le fasse "by myself"
Comme on dit
Oh Put*** Tu me fais peur quand tu fais ça
Elle est où ta queue ?
OUI !
J'ai jamais autant aimé une queue de ma vie
Non franchement, c'est trop pratique mon gars
Oh vous êtes des pervers c'est terrible ça !
Il a très bien compris que j'ai besoin d'aller là
et il m'y emmène immédiatement
Il est adorable
On y va
C'est parti
Tricot, c'est la folie
Alors, je passe de l'autre côté et je te dis
Là on peut monter
mais ça sert à rien.
J'ai compris je n'avais pas vu, il faut aller là
par derrière.
Putain faut vraiment observer, je n'ai pas encore tout à fait le réflexe de bien bien observer.
Oh qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ? Mais c'est à manger !
Trico
ça t'attire ça
ça il y a pas de soucis hein ya du monde
Est-ce que je lui file maintenant ?
Nan je pense qu'il faut que je le lance pour l'attirer
Ouais je vais l'attirer de l'autre côté avec
A mon avis c'est ça la strat
Je vais le mettre là
Et je vais baisser le levier
Et la porte s'ouvre
Oh putain merde !
Et voilà il a sauté pour la bouffe !
Ah non même pas pour la curiosité
Bon y'a de la bouffe si jamais Trico tu veux te mettre bien
Tiens regarde je te l'envoie
Hop là!
Allez bouffe
Bon allez viens on a pas le choix
Le problème c'est que qu'on veux monter rejoindre l'autre Trico
Et au final on descend
On est pas bien là. On es pas bon.
Alors? ... Qu'est-ce qu'on a en bas?
Droite ou gauche ?
Gauche on a
Un bon cul de sac
Et droite on a
Ouh la la la
Alors ça mon gars
Je pense Trico il va falloir que tu joue au chat perché là
Ca veut dire monte sur mon dos bâtard
C'est ça que ça veut dire ce cri?
Fais nous rêver chui prêt
Ou alors peut-être sniff beaucoup parce qu'il sens l'odeur de l'autre
Comme les animaux
Allez saute, je sais que tu dois sauter ici
Alors ça c'est une vue sur un gros trou de balle
Alors est-ce que le truc c'est qu'il a pas besoin que je lui file la bouffe qu'il cherche avant en fait
Ah mais c'est ça qu'il sent !
Mais voilà en fait faut y aller
Allez Trico on descend on y va !
C'est un peu haut
C'est bon x3
Ce petit garçon a des mollets solides
Y'a du manger ici
Oh c'est quoi y'a des armures !
Trico !
Comment je peux t'aider ?
Attend faut que je lui monte dessus sinon je vais me faire tuer
Faut que je lui monte dessus absolument
Trico vas-y
Faut que je monte sur toi attend Trico j'suis en danger
Vas-y tu les défonces
Il va me choper ! Il va me choper !
Trico vas-y défonces les !
Ah il lui mette des javelots
Non !
Pourquoi ils veulent nous séparer ?
J'ai vraiment besoin de monter sur toi
Oui Trico c'est bien
Extermine les
Allez jte retire le pieu
Oh putain il est blessé
Jte le retire x3 ça va
Désolé
T'en avais un deuxième
Ca va ça va
Attend attend calme toi
J'te le retire j'te caresse on est bon Trico
Comme à l'hôpital
Ca doit piquer. J'te caresse ça va mon grand
Ah c'est un indice ça dis donc
Allez mange vas-y ça va te redonner des forces
Vas-y je sais que t'en a envie
Régale toi
C'est bien mon grand
Ca va ?
T'as pris cher quand même dans la fight là
Allez on va essayer de s'en sortir
Il baille
Il a dû mettre 2-3 coups ça l'a fatigué
Faut que j'escalade ça
Allez
Hey la queue la grosse queue
Ah merde
Si c'est bon
Allez on continue
Mais fais pas du reculons marche euh
Enfin c'est pas pratique c'est pour toi que je dis ça
Ok on arrive dans un euh
Mais je comprends pas il faut qu'on monte et on fait que de descendre
C'est fait exprès c'est pour nous stresser
C'est pour nous dire putain ya un autre Trico il est là haut
AAH !
Trico !
Jvais mourir
J'ai vla besoin d'aide
Tricooo
Vas-y baise les moi j'cours hein
Ah merde c'est un cul de sac
Ok c'est bon il va se les faire
J'te soignerai démonte les
Défonce les ! Ah mais ils sont sous son ventre putain j'peux pas l'aider c'est horrible
Allez faut que j'monte
J'vais peut-être trouver une arme, un miroir un truc
En fait il est dans un endroit trop petit pour pouvoir se défendre
J'ai l'impression
C'est bon je crois qu'il les a démolit
Je suis désolé mais je sais pas qui c'est ces gens je sais pas ce qu'ils te veulent
Peut-être ils veulent te tuer pour faire un menteau 20 XL
J'aime pas voir Trico souffrir
J'suis sensible
Par contre là ce que je vois c'est que J'suis tout seul ici
Y'a plus Trico là
Ca craint un peu non ?
Y'a un long espace avec une porte bleue comme tout à l'heure
Purée mais à quoi elles servent ?
J'arrive x3 Trico, désoler
Ah te voilà mon grand !
T'as des lances plantées ou ça va aller ?
Je crois qu'ils étaient à l'épée cette fois
C'est pas forcément mieux mais...
Par là ya rien, ya rien du tout
Attend hop ah c'est là ! Super
Dans le couloir je ne l'avais point vu
Ah bah finalement ça nous avance pas à grand chose, mon gars
C'est juste des sortes de balcons
Euuuuh si j'fais le grand saut là, c'est la mort ?
J'ai envie de tenter ! Qui ne tente rien n'a rien !
Ouais non non
On parie combien va y avoir un guet-apens et la porte là-bas ya des soldats qui vont en sortir
Je pense que ça c'est le guet-apens
Viens Trico mais
Voilà
Euuuuh bon du coup on est enfermés ici tout les deux... En amoureux
Peut-être que l'autre Trico s'est fait piégé de la même manière et il a tué les gardes
Qu'est-ce qu'on en pense de cette théorie ?
Ah il est attiré par un truc, qu'est-ce tu regarde?
Ah là ya un levier comment on ouvre ça ? C'est ça l'énigme ?
Faut que je passe derrière la grille et pour aller derrière la grille
A mon avis je dois pouvoir trouver un accès, moi, par un petit trou, un petit truc
Et je vais faire le tour pour euuuuh
Pour aider bah voilà juste là tout simplement
Mec ya une putain de statut juste là je vais activer le levier et elle va se réveiller
Va falloir que je cours vers Trico
Je suis désolé Trico
C'est sûr elle va se réveiller
AH LA !
Oh le mec il blague pas du tout quoi Pascale le grand frère il a l'habitude d'attraper des enfants comme ça
C'est bon allez hop haha
Il va vraiment avoir beaucou d'hématomes à la fin du jeu ce gamin
Allez on y va Trico !
AAAAAAH !
Trico !
Ils ont des lances Trico
Euuuuuh
Mec je suis obligé de m'en remettre à toi j'espère que tu vas gérer
Jveux pas te voir mourir Trico
Voilà défonce les ! Ouais !
Je te caresse en même temps c'est ma manière de te donner du courage
Nice ! x2
Ca va il les défonce là ! Whaaa
Il perd pas temps mais bouffe les au pire bouffe les. Whaa! il perd pas de temps
Voilà comme ça, très bien !
Y'en a plus c'est bon ?
OK alors je vais juste te retirer les pieux que tu as
Désolé ! On est bon. Allez viens
Par contre euh ça c'est pas fou
Je pense que je vais devoir monter à l'échelle avant
Ah ya un sale garde là ! En plus il se tient comme un boss
tu sais le gars qu'attend genre le king qui a pas peur
Ah ouais c'est pour le levier de l'autre côté
C'est bon le levier est là
Ah faut que je tire c'est pas un, c'est une chaîne
Ah ouais mais le problème c'est je tire mais ça va revenir
Je pense que ce truc là est censé se lever avant
et à mon avis pour lever ce truc là il faut aller au bout là où y'a l'autre gardien
J'y vais en mode YOLO
Alors c'est toi le boss du donjon, qui bloque l'accès ?
Ah mais il vient jusque là Trico, ok bon bah je suis safe
Hey trou duc !
Ok il arrive en courant, il va démolir le garde !
Et bah voilà ça a pas loupé !
On est bien
C'est bon il est mort
Alors Trico, est-ce que tu saurais prendre ton envol pour aller de l'autre côté ?
C'est une question que je pose sincèrement
Oh fait gaffe tu vas me pousser dans le vide !
C'est pour que je monte sur toi que tu fais ça ? Allez vas-y fais le saut
Il va y aller là
Il adore me faire ce coup là putain
Ah là-haut ya un levier pardon pardon
Viens mon pote ya un levier par là
Ca te fait pas mal à force que jte tire les plumes comme ça ?
Faut qu'on atteigne le levier là-haut, allez on peut le faire
Tu m'aides?
bon
Bon à mon avis faut aller là bas
Là Trico veut rien faire il a dit moi je vais AFK j'en ai marre
Et ben voillà pfff
Merci LucasHauchard (en chantant)
Mais c'est pas évident je pensais qu'on pouvait atteindre le levier alors qu'en fait non
Bon j'ai pas trop encore la notion des hauteurs qu'on peut atteindre
Et des hauteurs qu'on peut pas atteindre
Oh la la c'est beau ici dis donc
Faut que j'escalde ?Ah ya de la bouffe !
J'pense qu'en fait avant de lui demander de faire un effort, il faut lui donner à bouffer
Voilà à quoi sert la bouffe !
Vous savez la dernière j'étais pas sûr si c'était pour lui donner du pouvoir ou pas
Ben je pense qu'en fait c'est juste pour qu'il obéisse
Sinon il s'en bat les couilles de toi en vrai *rire*
Ah ça se lève ! Là ya de la bouffe ça se lève, là ya du monde !
Vooiiilà !
Ah là il regarde le saut... Attends moi attends moi !
J'ai cru qu'il allait sauter sans moi j'ai eu très peur
Pire que rater un train de la SNCF...
Rater un saut de Trico
Ne me prend pas pour un imbécile Trico
Allez vas-y t'y va !
Allez t'y vas !
Faut qu'on aille là-haut à gauche là haut à gauche
AAAH j'pensais qu'on pouvais s'accrocher !
Oh putain jme suis... Mais attend j'peux passer moi à travers
Ca fait 20 minutes que j'essaie mon gars de trouver quoi faire j'pouvais juste passer entre les barreaux
*Rire*
Mais tu sais quand tu vois une grille tu cherches pas à, t'sais c'est comme quand t'es en prison ya une grille tu cherches pas à sortir
J'ai fait beaucoup de prison... C'est faux
Ah merde bon bah maintenant on saura
Vu que c'est le début du jeu on connait pas encore toutes les mécaniques
et je pense que de toute manière tout au long du jeu on va en découvrir des nouvelles
Oh le con!
Ouh la, là ya beaucoup de trucs ouh la la
Ya une caisse à déplacer qui va nous permettre d'atteindre un endroit à mon avis
Où faut qu'on aille ici ? pu pu pu
On a deux caisses... Ah bah il est là !
J'ai même pas vu comment t'as fait
T'as fait quoi t'es passé entre les barreaux aussi ?
T'es un vrai chat quoi ! T'es comme ça, puis t'arrive à devenir comme ça
Je crois pas que Trico mange les barrils si ils sont dans une caisse
Oh ! Ben t'as pété la caisse... ah bah si si pète celle la aussi
Ah si il va y arriver en fait
Nan mais tu viens d'en casser une me dit pas que celle là tu la casses pas
Ah *rire* vas-y mange mon grand
Franchement régale toi, vla à bouffer
Je sais toujours pas à quoi sert la bouffe... Peut-être que chui con, peut-être que vous l'aurez deviné
Alors donnez des ordres, tout en maintenant R1 contrôllez le garçon pour donner des ordres
Ah donc maintenant j'peux donner des ordres, je lui ai donné assez de bouffe pour qu'il m'obéisse
J'le caresse... oh c'est miiignon !
Ah ok jpeux lui dire d'aller à un endroit précis maintenant
X (croix) c'est pour lui dire au pied
O (rond) c'est pour lui dire... c'est pour lui dire quoi, d'applaudir ?
Bon ◄ (triangle)  c'est pour sauter
Et ♦ carré c'est pour... pousser
D'accord !
D'accord maintenant je peux vraiment lui donner des ordres, lui dire où aller, lui dire quoi faire
C'est génial ça!
Hey j'vais lui faire faire du cirque mon frère, j'vais faire fortune
On peut maintenant lui donner des ordres
J'ai fais 2-3 tests, on peux lui dire au pied
Voilà il s'arrête il s'est assis
On peut lui dire allez debout tu te lèves ! Il se relève
On peut lui dire de sauter et on peut lui indiquer les endroits où on veut qu'il aille
Comme ça en pointant du doigt
Je pense que si vous adorez les animaux comme moi, vous allez adorer ce jeu
C'est con mais on dirait tellement un vrai animal
Je pense qu'ils ont volé mon chat discrètement, les développeurs
Pendant des nombreuses années du coup, vu le temps de développement du jeu
Il l'ont entouré de capteurs et c'est là qu'est né Trico
Qui me rappelle tant ma Lua
Jumbo pas trop, il est moins gracieux, il sait s'allonger et ... il sait pas faire d'autres trucs
Et ben à bientôt pour le prochain épisode, je mettrais en ligne un épisode tous les 2 jours je pense
même si ça tombe sur un jour où je met déjà une vidéo de base
C'est pas grave vous aurez 2 vidéos à matter !
Let's play je vous conseille ça juste avant de dodo, ça vous apaise, on est bien en jouant à ça
Allez à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo, merci d'avoir regardé, portez-vous bien ciao tout le monde
Peace !